[Music]
as we enter our eighth month of living
in a pandemic
it's okay to feel like you're still
struggling to adjust
this is a tough time and we all know the
big things we're losing this year but
we're also losing a lot of little things
we've had to give up
a lot of experiences that we used to
take for granted
and to recognize them we'd like to
present an
in memoriam for all our lost experiences
this year we lost a lot of our most
treasured experiences
experiences such as trying a new
restaurant
working out at the gym getting stuck in
a conversation
at a house party and saying for sure
a bunch of times while you try to figure
out how to get out of it
taking an uber pool with three complete
strangers
touching all the new phones at the apple
store because you got a little extra
time on your lunch break
going to see a movie and right before
you found out the husband did it
the person behind you whispers the
husband did it
figuring out how my friends and i want
to split the check at a restaurant
should we put it all on ramone's card
and then we can venmo him
or do we want to put down six different
cards and make the restaurant figure it
out
oh melissa has cash that's going to
complicate things too
seeing a critically acclaimed broadway
production of death of a salesman
after it's been recommended to me by
many friends
and then falling asleep until
intermission
only to leave and get a small cup of
coffee that i can drink to keep me awake
for the rest of the play
and then return to my seat and think wow
this seat is a lot more comfortable than
seats at the theater need to be
and i fall asleep yet again watching a
fight unfold between the two people in
front of you at a hot dog stand
obviously you can't get involved but
you're right there
going to a family cookout and having my
uncle leroy take one look at me and go
boy you're supposed to be growing up not
out
like he does every year reinforcing a
deeply held sense of
poor body image hugging your least
favorite cousin at thanksgiving and then
doing a secret handshake with your
favorite cousin immediately after
kissing europeans on the cheek
when you first meet them kissing
europeans on the mouth when you first
meet them
boy it's been a long year of lost
experiences
and there are still so many things we're
going to lose down the line
but remember we are doing this
not just for ourselves but for our
friends and loved ones
who want nothing more than to join us at
a crowded bar
they didn't know was cash only until
after they'd already ordered a drink
so please stay inside and wear a mask
if you have to go out do it for uncle
leroy
this has been in memoriam
[Music]
[Applause]
you